[Musique]
les petits chanteurs de la chorale les
jeunes instrumentistes les danseurs et
les élèves d'arts plastiques avec leurs
décors l'école artistique intercommunal
de l'ouest présente son spectacle un an
de travail pour ce projet pédagogique
qui invite savourer les talents
multiples et l'interdisciplinarité
l'oeuvre intitulée nos voix est signée
vincent bellec un musicien professeurs
intervenants de cette école
le projet nos voix donc c'est sur dix
tableaux dix tableaux je parle de karma
karma c'est l'idée c'est de trouver un
équilibre j'avais écrit ce titre lors
des attentats de nice mais ceux d'avant
voilà donc comme quoi j'avais besoin
d'exprimer des choses par en musique
c'est un honneur un honneur de recevoir
aussi trois artistes doubt tania
boristhène et marie alice in amant
ensuite il ya aussi l'équipe des
professeurs qui accompagnent les élèves
donc c'est ça vraiment cette idée c'est
que les élèves puissent aussi jouer avec
des professionnels à travers une dizaine
de tableaux donc nos voix illustre une
quête des valeurs universelles les
enfants les adolescents sont heureux de
collaborer à ce projet collectif
mais moi je fais de la trompette flûte
traversière batterie pettis c'est une
grande opportunité de monter sur scène
c'est en plus théâtre plein hier s'est
passé pas n'importe quoi quoi donc
pour profiter nos voir un rendez-vous
d'émotion surtout pour les parents ce
dimanche soir 19 heures à saint gilles
[Musique]
quand comme moi